hello everyone and welcome to another
remarkable game that I found uh well
again while scrolling Twitter it seems
to be the uh the the place to find the
interesting games just base India posted
an article about
um the tournament and about round five
uh of the of the uh faganist Autumn
Grand Master tournament and this is a
truly amazing game between vaishali and
uh Grandmaster saturaman and uh
interestingly uh both vaishali and her
brother are pregnant and are playing in
this tournament and they are both doing
uh incredibly well as you'll see later
on we're gonna discuss the standings a
little bit but this game truly stands
out the chess base India channel uh
deemed that a perhaps a a vaishali
Immortal and for a very good reason so
let's dive straight into it as she's
facing a very very strong Grand Master
rated over 200 rating points okay it's
not over 200 but almost 200 rating
points um above her so let's uh check it
out so here we have E4 and pawn to C5
goes for the Sicilian Defense we have
Knight to F3 by vaishali D6 D4 end
character's character so very standard
stuff here Knight to F6 Knight the C3
and A6 the Knight of defense and there
are many many popular options here that
you can go for uh lately even Rook to G1
has been a popular one but here we have
Bishop to D3 this is only the 10th most
popular option but in the neither of
that also means that many many games
have been played in this slide so G6
preparing to film get to the bishop we
have Pawn to F3 and now not Bishop to G7
which is a standard move here but Pawn
to E5 first and now there are only a
handful of games that have reached this
exact position so Knight back to B3 we
have Bishop to E6 and the bishop to E3
now we have Knight beta D7 so nicely
developing and there is a game between
Arya and Chopra and Jordan fan Forest
that was played this year in the Abu
Dhabi Masters that ended in a draw where
A4 was played by Aryan Chopra but here
we have Queen the D2 by vaishali and it
is now as of move tender we have a
completely new game so obviously saying
that she will cast the queen side and as
a duraman continues in the pretty
standard fashion B5 then you you can
maybe play Rook the C8 or depending on
what white plays you can even play A5 A4
or B4 uh so really depends how uh
vaishali will play this and
interestingly you can still Castle
King's side here it would be the safe
thing to do but it would not be the cool
thing to do here we have castles uh
Queen side and now Queen to C7 okay just
putting some pieces in front of the
white king we have pawned the F4 going
after the black king that's still in the
center of the board and now as a tourman
says that is way too slow I'm just gonna
start my thing on the queen side so B4
and now Knight back to E2 again very
interesting Knights the D2 is solid and
it's a very forcing line that sort of
gives a white the attack but not really
point is that you can give up a pawn
here captures captures now let's say
Knight captures on D5 you capture here
black capture serial capture here and
then I captures on E5 and okay black is
up upon white still maybe can do
something as the black king is in the
center of the board but there is no D
Pawn or F Pawn to dislodge this knight
from E5 you don't have a dark Square
Bishop the Knight needs a few jumps to
get uh to this Knight and black will
just play Bishop G7 Castle King side and
that's pretty much it black is just up
upon so it's not
uh it's it's not all that much so
vaishali goes nice to E2 instead we have
Pawn to A5 still saying you are too slow
on the king side we have King to B1 even
time for a nice prophylactic move and
now we have Bishop to E7
uh you could start pushing right away
but the tournament says there is no rush
I can only always play A4 there's really
no good way to stop this with H3 now
Michelle is preparing G4 and pawn to H5
now stopping G4 but not really why
Charlie goes for it pawn to G4 and now
still it's uh probably better to just
play A4 but saturaman goes for a a Tong
wrap captures captures we have Rook
captures on each one Rook counters and
H1 and now Bishop captures on G4 and now
it seems that you're just up a clean
Pawn but still you have given white a
little something maybe A4 in that
position would have been more solid for
black but okay Rook the h8 with check
and now Bishop to f8 and this bishop to
f8 is the root of all problems for black
still with Knight to f8 uh you are still
playing this game and you don't really
mind what white is doing but after
Bishop to fate uh everything just uh
sort of Falls in place here we have F
captures on E5 5D captures on E5 and now
Bishop to B5 so now not only is the
bishop here uh immobilized but also the
Knight on D7
so King E7 as a tournament uh unpinned
from everything and now Bishop to G5
creating another pin here not allowing
the Knight to move and here you have to
play Queen to D6 or for a queen trade
and hope for for the best because this
is not an easy position for black to
play but still vaishali could probably
play something like Queen E1 and then
the game continues in in a very
aggressive fashion but after king a
queen the B7 uh the position is just
lost for black it's such a spectacular
line that uh well I'm gonna ask you guys
to pause the video and try to find it
and this is only the first pause the
video of the video moment uh as we will
have three of them so you know choose
your time wisely so have at it while I
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
uh night uh
ETA D4 that's the good stuff now uh it's
such a subtle difference between night
between night eat the D4 and Knight B to
D for death both vaishali and saturum
and Mister because vaishali played
Knight B to D4 and saturum did not
punish it for those of you who maybe
thought of A4 this is uh also very nice
this is also winning for white but this
is uh I mean just you know uh other
engine nonsense we're not going to even
discuss this uh but the reason why
Knight beat the D4 is uh not a great and
why Knight eat the D4 is the great we
first have to show why what happens if
Knight eat the D4 the point is now that
after e captures on D4 and this is by
far the best move you play Bishop
captures on D7 and now the problem is
you can't really play Queen captures on
D7 because if you play Queen captures
then Queen to F4 now threatening to
capture on F6 and after something trying
to defend this you just play Knight
captures on D4 attack the queen and
after the queen moves still keeping an
eye on the Knight here you just push the
pawn and now there is no stopping this
capture and also the Knight is defended
so that's why it loses the real reason
why it loses is that even if King
captures on D4 you play Queen captures
on D4 and now uh the problem is uh well
there is no good move Bishop to D6 would
be nice unfortunately it runs into this
Royal Fork Knight to C5 check and you
lose the queen because there's a bishop
now in between the queen and the king so
that's why it doesn't work the
difference is after this queen to B7
move why you should play Knight E to D4
and not Knight beta D4 as it was played
in the game is exactly this bishop on f8
because now uh but it seems if I surely
convinced the tournament that this is
also winning but now he captures on D4
is actually be perfectly fine for black
which was not played in the game I I'm
just going to show you why because after
Bishop characters King captures now
Queen captures on D4 simply runs into
Bishop to D6 and there is no Knight on
B3 to deliver this deadly Fork the the
Knight is an E2 because the wrong Knight
came to D4 and now after let's say
captures captures okay it still looks
somewhat scary but after Queen captures
here Queen E8 and there's really not all
that much you can do even for example
Knight F4 Bishop F5 and it's white who
has back rank issues so
uh it's not going to be easy and the D4
Pawn is hanging so that's the way to do
it but uh she was able uh to take him
deep into the forest and he he did not
find the the correct solution he played
Rook the C8 and now comes uh and as they
said it and uh chess base India's um uh
our article that uh that I I read uh
Knight the F4 she puts her Knights into
a double Fork basically the Knight is
now double the pawn is not double
forking the knights here uh incredible
stuff this is not something you see very
rare and okay you might see it if black
attacks the two knights but I've never
seen uh someone Place both of their
knights in in a pawn Fork but okay and
now uh what do you do you can't capture
this Knight you can't capture this
Knight it's very uh tricky why if you
capture this Knight then Queen captures
an F4 uh and how are you dealing with
this also this Knight is attacked so
this uh you can just remove the defender
capture here it's not any issue and if
Bishop G7 you can even play Rook
captures on C8 and after Queen captures
just E5 so nothing really changes
another thing instead of e captures on
F4 you could capture on B4 which is a
little bit better but still after Bishop
captures here King captures you will
play Rook captures on f8 now and after
Rook captures Queen captures on D4 again
you put pressure on the Knight here and
uh there's no no good way to to get out
of this the king is in check you have to
move the king king to see it but now
Queen C5 check for example takes out the
The Rook on f8 Queen C7 captures here
you're gonna play King B7 Bishop
captures on F6 and you're just um uh
well even after Queen captures on F4
grabbing back the piece you can play
Queen captures on F7 and now it would be
very dangerous to try and walk around
with the king so best would be to try
and trade Queens but then just Queen
captures on G6 and by Charlotte would be
up two pawns with a past E Pawn maybe
black can save this somehow as okay
Bishops are of opposite color but it
should not be an issue here but okay
after Knight to F4 he plays the absolute
best Queen captures on A4 which is all I
mean you it would seem that you are able
to capture one of the knights but uh no
you're not so here comes Knight the C6
with check and now there is only one
good move for black here and that is to
play Rook captures on C6 which was not
played in the game but the point is you
have to play this
and now it's sort of a a force to draw
Knight to D5 with check as this Knight
cannot move King the E6 now you're gonna
capture on C6 Knight captures on the E5
Bishop countress on D7 King captures
Rook captures and f8 and after this
capture Fest uh you know is is over now
we have the very nice King E6 you have
to play this uh defending F7 adding more
defense to the knight in here probably
we would see a repetition King D6 Rook
d8 King D6 or something like this uh or
maybe not but it's just one of the
possibilities the problem is after
Knight the C6 check satoroman has had it
with this game and he doesn't find it he
plays King the E8 and now it seems like
uh he solved everything there is no good
way to continue the attack the problem
is uh there is there is only one move
that wins the game for vaishali so again
feel free to pause the video and try and
spot this one while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh deciding on
this move as it's not a move you would
think about playing and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Bishop captures on F6 such a weird move
because you really like this bishop here
controlling the DA square you're you're
probably probably wondering how to give
some sort of a sneaky Checkmate uh the
thing is this is uh just this works just
perfectly because now if you capture the
bishop with the Knight there's there's a
discovery Knight captures on B4 Shifting
the Knight over to D5 so it's check from
the bishop and even after Bishop D7
there's Knight B to D5 now threatening
this disgusting Fork Knight capture whoa
Knight captures on F6 would be Fork
forking the king and the Queen and even
after captures and captures the fork is
still being threatened and there's
nothing you can do here there there's no
move for you here so best thing would be
to play Queen captures and C2 try and
trade down a little bit after Queen
captures Rook captures the problem is at
the end of line bishop captress and D7
check King captures and King captures on
C2 by Charlie would end up being uh
upper full Rook so after this Rook uh
Bishop captures on F6 Knight captures
and F6 doesn't work rather Rook captures
on C6 was played and now again only one
move that wins the game for vaishali so
feel free to pause the video for the
last time the third and last time while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
black is getting checkmated and the
problem is this this is the problem look
at this look at this bishop look at this
rook and look at the queen here yes
that's exactly what's happening and here
congratulations to everyone who founded
the vaishali played Knight to D5 and now
there's just nothing to be done here the
Knight has actually nothing to do with
the attack it could have okay but mainly
the Knight moves the three of the H6
Square for the queen and now whatever
you're playing it just resigns uh to
give you an example if Bishop T6 okay
you add one Defender there's the simple
Rook captures on f8 King captures and
queen to H6 check King to E8 not trying
to free up the f8 square for the night
but okay even this doesn't work but
there's the spectacular Knight C7 check
which forces the capture and then the
Knight will uh be uh just stuck here
unable to move and after Rook captures
now Queen to AJ this Checkmate as the
Knight is been the Knight cannot move so
after Knight the D5 Rook captures and C2
was played now threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries once The Rook moves
but not like Charlie just plays a rook
captures on f8 and he was in this
position on move 28 yes to only 28 moves
but we've seen so many lines that it's
like it's been 70 Moves uh that
satoroman has resigned the game and a
brilliant brilliant victory for by
Charlie in round five of this uh
incredibly strong tournament uh so yeah
very nicely done by Charlie taking down
a 200 rating points uh high rated Grand
Master so very nicely done and again you
resign because of the same idea if
capture is just Queen to H6 check and
that's it regardless of King theater
King to G8 uh Queen to h8 will be
Checkmate as the Knight already cannot
move so a a remarkable game and uhuraman
had that one chance where he could have
saved himself but after I mean Knight
beat to D4 it was such a uh such a uh
funny moment that uh it was I mean
incredibly hard to realize that this
Knight would deliver the deadly uh Royal
Fork that would end the game in this
line but vaishali just wanted to pin uh
to Fork a self Fork both of her Knights
uh and you know it turned out very well
so a beautiful beautiful win against a
very strong Grandmaster In This Very
thematic game
uh and yeah like I said she's doing
incredibly well in the tournament she's
on four out of five uh in in a very
strong competition uh pregnant and dies
is on four and a half out of five and
the tournament is uh being led with a
perfect five out of five by Anton
damchenko so uh obviously he he's doing
incredibly well but this was uh the game
that caught my attention so I decided to
show this one uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it big
congratulations to vaishalian such a
spectacular win uh I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Shannon we've
heard in previous video that she allows
her husband to watch chess videos
whenever he wants so that's really
awesome and I would like to thank Alan
winnery uh Len Herbert congratulations
Dr Tako and Francis air for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day